es geht auch um emotionen in diesem
krieg und in einem bewegenden und
besonderen appell auf instagram richten
sich auch die klitschko brüder wladimir
und vitali der bürgermeister von kehrt
direkt an die spirituellen führer der
welt die ukraine und seine bürger jetzt
zu unterstützen
betroffen wäre vor ringen über das drama
dass ich in diesem moment in der ukraine
abspielt stellt inbegriff der
menschlichkeit erfragen die würde des
menschen die so durch die freiwillige
aggression gegen die zivilbevölkerung
und die ausschreitungen die überall aus
dem boden meines landes zu nehmen und
frage gestellt was ich im herzen europas
abspielt berührt dass er es alle
bewohner unseres planeten die
gerechtigkeit und die werte des im leben
unabhängig von ihrer herkunft oder
religion
ich appelliere ausdrücklich an die
geistigen führer dieser welt stellung zu
beziehen und die innen verpflichten der
moralische funktion und mit stolz die
verantwortung ihrer religion für unseren
frieden zu übernehmen so wende ich mich
an seiner heiligkeit papst franziskus
mit mohammed eltern an den dalai lama
den oberrabbiner israels david bach und
dem patriarchen kyrill den ersten und
lade sie einst nach kiew zu kommen um
ihre solidarität mit dem ukrainischen
volk zu bekunden ihr mitgefühl zu zeigen
und sich im geist der harmonie zu
vereinen in mein land und die ganze welt
brauchen lassen sie uns jetzt zur
hauptstadt der menschlichkeit der
spiritualität und des friedens macht die
einigkeit ist unser schlüssel für
frieden
dann bewegen der appell regeneration
paul ronzheimer der in kiew ist die
klitschko brüder immer wieder trifft
paul hilft nur noch beten
beten hilft hoffentlich thomas bislang
ist die russische armee ihr ins zentrum
der hauptstadt nicht vorgerückt was
vitali und wladimir klitschko dort
wollen ist nicht anderes als in stellen
bürger die spirituellen lieder ihr zu
versammeln in kiew die sagen wir nach
kiew um mit anderen und das könne am
ende dafür sorgen dass diese stadt
geschützt wird eine eine initiative ja
die sicherlich sinn hat aber wir werden
sehen ob der papst und andere diese
einladung annehmen aber es ist immer
wieder erstaunlich paul auf welche ideen
um es mal so zu formulieren auf welche
ideen die ukraine kommen egal ob
selensky der sagt jetzt muss die nato
her egal ob
der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland der sagt wir brauchen jetzt
panzer und jetzt haben die klitschkos
der papst soll kommen die forderungen
sind hoch geschraubt aber sie haben auch
eine enorme wirkung um einen druck
aufzubauen
genau diesen druck geht es thomas es
geht darum dass die welt nicht aufhört
hier auf diese stadt zu schauen auf
dieses land zuschaut dort wo peter
berichtet hat wo wir berichten wo so
viele menschen darum bangen dass es
weitere raketen und bomben hier geben
kann und die gab es heute ja wir sehen
das im osten wird weiter geschossen wir
sehen das in den vororten gehen trifft
die lage bleibt dramatisch die ist
dramatisch und alle gehen davon aus dass
guti noch härter waffen einsetzen wird
in den nächsten tag